when we feel certain sort of irritation
during that moment if that person also
take fully on the breathing nothing else
breathing 1 2 3 5 10 15 20 when you
understate irritate it but then after 20
30 basing your mental state will be a
little different little more calm since
we are dealing with emotions or the best
method to deal with that is so the so
called meditation not for next life not
for heaven but is it for day two days
well being then I think the best method
to avoid fear or regret at the time of
death is while we are alive our time our
energy must utilize meaningful way
decisive the most profitable drug way of
what meaning of usefulness
once all survival even animals also can
do
but for service to other is something
unique about human being
so serving other people helping other
people
ester I think very very appropriate sort
of action according our intelligence
strength or human ability we have such
our ability so then utilize that ability
Posada in the most appropriate way of
most appropriate way is selling other
people then at the end you'll feel no
regret you just watched two amazing
clips from the Dalai Lama take three
minutes to sit quietly and think about
how you can apply them to your business
and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]